another keeping them honest moment
people are climbing
over donald trump's 15 billion dollar
border wall with ladders made from
five dollars in raw materials um we have
a new report
from the texas monthly that the u.s
mexico border wall
is being regularly breached using
homemade
ladders border patrol
this would almost be a comedy uh if it
weren't a tragedy
border patrol officials are regularly
finding discarded ladders beside the
wall
the walls are the ladders are so cheap
that
they just it's five bucks in materials
and then they just get left behind
and one activist told texas monthly that
the ladders defeating the wall that cost
12 million dollars per mile
contained five dollars worth of
ingredients of of uh materials
u.s border patrol officials who monitor
the wall frequently are finding
the ladders made by unauthorized
immigrants who cross into texas
along certain parts of the wall the
texas monthly report cites scott nichol
who's an activist and texas resident as
business insider reports
saying quote these ladders are probably
five dollars worth of hardware
and they're defeating a wall that cost
12 million dollars a mile
in that location he also added unlike
unlike the wall
the ladders are functional um trump
of course promised to build an
impenetrable wall
across the entire u.s mexico border
by the end of his first term which
mexico would pay for
trump did not build the wall mexico
didn't pay for the little bits and
pieces that trump did build
and it is not impenetrable there are
videos dating all the way back to
when you know years ago of uh people
scaling the wall using a ladder and then
sliding down the other side with about a
hundred dollars worth of stuff from our
hardware store
now they are finding ladders often made
from just a few dollars of scrap
lumber and regularly finding them all up
and down
uh that that that border wall
border patrol now drives around grabbing
the ladders
and destroying them and then putting
them together
into piles which later are hauled off
into landfills so like ev every aspect
of this
is just mind-numbingly but
mind-numbingly stupid and
in total uh trump after pledging mexico
would fund the work um
mexico didn't pay for it and the 15
billion that went into it came from
federal taxes
and only something like 50 miles of new
50 or 90 new
miles of actual border wall were built
so
we are it's it's going to take years to
learn the full scope
of the scam that was the trump
presidency sweetheart crony deals
that never end up happening
announcements of jobs and factories
that never end up happening an
impenetrable wall
that supposedly would be completed by
the end of the first term paid for by
mexico which wasn't paid for by mexico
and wasn't completed and was
scalable or or passable with just a few
dollars of discarded lumber it's all
been
a major major scam and it will take some
time for us to know the full scope of it
sad more than anything i take no
pleasure in it um
it's it's humiliating actually when you
talk to people from other countries
what's going on
we have a fantastic program for you
today let me know your thoughts
on the wall failure by finding me
on twitter at d pacman we will take some
of your calls i will
answer some of your questions and so
much more coming up today
more and more people i know are eating a
more heavily plant-based diet the way
i've been doing for years both for
health and environmental reasons and for
many people
it can be tough to know where to start
and find tasty recipes but one of our
sponsors smartieplants
is an online platform that can help you
don't have to be vegan or vegetarian i'm
neither and it's still great and they
have a 28-day
kickstart plan that makes it easy to add
plant-based foods to your life
they provide daily recipes grocery lists
tips about parties traveling restaurants
smartie plants has recipes i've been
loving i've made pizza
mac and cheese brownies and tacos which
are maybe my favorite
smarty plants turns eating plant-based
into something easy
fun and truly delicious and it's better
for you
and for the planet smarty plants is
offering a huge 50 percent discount on
their 28-day kickstart
it's a one-time fee of 17 bucks go to
smartypants.org
pacman and use the code pacman 50
the link is down below